I woke up today just like a hive man
looks like Kenta is coming on got my
beads you just feel just like it when
tricity it's like Black Panther we are
here to talk about Black Panther and the
kingdom of Wakanda and how incredible
this moment is Black Panther right it's
just a superhero movie no no it's so
much more than that there's a different
kind of excitement you can feel
something is happening for the culture
so some friends of mine invited me to go
to an advanced screening with the
African artist Association and watch
this movie with a bunch of proud African
people and to just really see like what
does this movie actually mean for us for
our culture for our people moving
forward and to get to really tap into it
on a more personal level on a deeper
level of what that means for being black
in America and for us celebrating our
culture especially this time during
Black History Month this feels like a
moment it doesn't feel like there's
something in the air there's something
spiritual that's happening you're like
it's just a movie man like calm down I
don't get it like don't get too high if
it's just a movie but then it's like
it's a movie it's generated so much
interest so much excitement so much
momentum it's like we feel something
special here to me representation
matters Black Panther I see myself the
only time I've ever been able to see
myself in films it's either genocide
movie Oh
slavery movie but now I can see myself
as a queen people are so excited for it
never seen planning the outfits for the
premium they call their designer friend
hey can you make me a dress for Black
Panther it's almost like we're part of
the movie it's not a red carpet full as
we're fans going to watch a movie about
the same time it's actually a part of it
we're gonna show up you know royalty
kings and queens for you it was
different because you're in the mood I
am honestly everyone in Hollywood knew
that this movie was happening we were
all like rooting for it every single one
of my friends my peers were like yo we
gotta get
Panther mayor how do we get in Black
Panther actors were like calling
production like I'm willing to work on
this thing for free just hi I don't know
hey I just want to be a part of it being
on the sad it was just incredible you
were in the presence of people who knew
that there was something really
tremendous happening to just see Ryan
Coogler like in control of this huge
production the best technology the best
actors I mean it's really marrying black
culture African culture being a first
generation Ghanaian American you always
kind of questioned your place am i
American and my African you know with
trying to identify as African American
it's about a dialogue between Africans
and African Americans it's a really
important you know conversations have
and it's a really important idea to
explore it's a dream that we're having
for ourselves that isn't being
instigated by it you see people from the
Caribbean you see people from the UK
used to do from East Africa from West
Africa from America and it's bringing
together this unifying of all these
different types of black what it does is
it heals us minority culture is a hungry
yeah they're just hungry and in the time
has come where the hunger will see
greatness that has not been presented at
all what do you think that's gonna do
for these next generations of kids to
get to see this like what kind of impact
do you think it can have I know how
powerful imagery is I know how powerful
movies are and especially when you're a
kid to be able to see people that look
like you dark-skinned on screen as
superheroes they're smart they're
elegant and they're still paying respect
to the tradition and the value culture
like for me it's like the youth you can
see that and dream about what's possible
in Africa Curtis and I are here outside
in front of Grauman's on Hollywood
Boulevard this energy is incredible to
see Black Panthers with the African
Artists Association here we go we can't
wait to see this
was that amazing or what
gods did you feel my heart I not call
the Green Onyx it was so emotional like
they went in on the whole like
separation between Africa
it is by far one of the most powerful
just I can't even put it in words to see
African black I'm still the bird of like
the connection of tears of the emotion
[Music]
to get it yeah I get it
I'm like literally go like dead ass like
emotional right now yeah it's gorgeous
yeah
[Music]
you